update for you authorities captured two
men accused of killing members of the
same family in the Tiny Town of Goshen
California the January attack left six
people dead including a grandmother in
her 70s and a 16 year old mother and her
baby in newly released surveillance
video you can see that young mom drop
her infant over the fence then climbs
the then climbs the gate herself trying
to get away she and the child were shot
execution Style just up the road as part
of what's being called operation
nightmare authorities took Angel uriarty
and Noah beard into custody uriarty got
into a gunfight with ATF agents and had
been hospitalized he's actually expected
to survive the sheriff says that when
investigators served warrants on the two
suspects they also served warrants at
several state prisons searching specific
cells and inmates with gang affiliations
and connections at least two people at
the home survived the attack and one
called 9-1-1
for coming back
we're coming back oh they're coming back
in
who's coming back in the guys please
hurry come on
the Tulare County Sheriff gave an update
on the people involved saying this is
all part of a long-standing gang war in
the Central Valley of California
in the beginning I had mentioned it was
a cartel-like shooting
and as all of you can imagine this is
exactly what it appears to be rivalry
games between the Nortenos and the
serenos which we have all heard of many
many times
the two members of the peraz family the
victims family
we're well-known validated serenos
Sereno gang members in the town of
Goshen
which is predominantly held by the
Norteno gang
the two suspects arrested today
are validated volcanoes the suspects and
the victims have a long history of gang
violence
heavily active in guns gang violence gun
violence and narcotics dealings
however having said that the motive
is not exactly clear at this point
Brian please say there's no motive for
the killings at least yet but do the
gang affiliations of the suspects and
two of the victims they have to give us
some sort of clue right absolutely Jesse
when it comes to getting affiliation and
killings like this you've got to think
it's most likely one of two things
either it's about territory or it's
about revenge it's either an expansion
of a territory one gang saying hey we're
moving in on your Turf so to speak and
this is a signal both to these
individuals and their families and other
gang members associated with the victims
or it's about revenge you don't go
killing people execution style along
with their family members unless
something happened in the past I again
would say this is either about turf or
it's about revenge but I think once we
dig down a little deeper and we get into
the nitty-gritty so to speak all the
relationship between these two gangs and
recent shootings killings and movements
we'll definitely get a motive and if we
dig down a little deeper I thought it
was fascinating Terry that the law
enforcement search inmate sells for
evidence it makes me wonder if we're
going to expect additional people to be
charged as a result of this oh I think
absolutely they're going to charge
additional people this is what led them
to making these arrests the fact that
they found this information in the cells
and I do think that anybody who had some
sort of connection to these murders
could be charged for solicitation of
murder or a murder For Hire we're in
California and if that's the case they
can be charged with those crimes and if
someone was injured in the crime they
could get up to 20 years if no one was
injured they did 10 years but here we
have you know people who were killed so
in fact they could get life or death
obviously death is not an option right
now in California because there's a
moratorium and they're not pursuing it
anymore but yes I definitely think they
could charge some of the individuals who
were behind bars along with those who
were outside doing the crime and that
video is just so absolutely chilling
watching that hearing the 911 phone call
well a Florida man who now admits to
torturing and killing two gay men 20
years ago is insistent he wants the
death penalty Stephen Lorenzo is
representing himself during his
sentencing this week and explained to a
judge on Monday why he wants the death
penalty
yes give me the death penalty that is
absolutely great that's exactly what I
want I'm 64 years old it can take I
could be on debt for over 10 15 years
the Comfort set they get in the death
row a lot more comfortable than it is in
the federal system you get your own
private sale you get your own TV you get
your own computer you get all this stuff
but your privacy your daily quality of
life privacy at my age is is that
invaluable I want to do my time my way
it's easy time so I'm going anyway as
far as I'm concerned everybody here is
on death row everybody's got to go
sometime
well Lorenzo was convicted in Tampa in
2005 and given a 200 year federal prison
sentence Lorenzo sent a long handwritten
letter from jail to the 13th judicial
circuit court before Thanksgiving giving
saying he wants to plead guilty have a
judge sentence him to death and waive
his right to appeal a judge is expected
to make a decision sometime this week
[Music]
and welcome back everybody a Texas
bartender is under arrest accused of
over serving a man who decided to drive
drunk and kill the police officer Dylan
Molina told police that he'd been
drinking in November 2021 when he ran a
red light and slammed into a car driven
by detective Alex Cervantes during their
investigation police determined Molina
had been at a Fuzzy's Taco Stop in Lake
Worth and they believed that Calla
Richardson over served an already
intoxicated Molina police also
discovered that Richardson's license to
serve liquor was expired Molina pleaded
guilty last month and was sentenced to
15 years in prison as for Richardson
well she faces up to a year in prison
and a four thousand dollar fine for
allegedly over serving Molina Brian is
this a thing charging a bartender for
what a patron does it seems like there
has to be a defense there yeah so this
is a thing Jesse let's go take us all
the way back to law school it's actually
called dram shop laws dram shop being
another word for bars or establishments
where alcohol is served and they've been
around since the 19th century the
Mothers Against Drunk Driving has
actually made us a very big law in the
United States Canada New Zealand and
even Australia and what the idea is if
you are serving someone who is visibly
intoxicated you are liable for their
actions afterwards a potential defense
could be that they were doing everything
they should have been doing checking
their patrons as they were coming in and
that they did not observe this person to
be visually visibly intoxicated and
therefore had no reason to believe that
they could not serve them more alcohol
of course that is a difficult argument
to make there's a lot of factual
implications that go back and forth as
to what they did or did not observe but
it's a thing make sure you're watching
who you're serving alcohol when you're
working at these establishments Terry
you agree with this you agree with
holding people responsible for serving
too much alcohol because if so where do
you draw the line you know I do agree
with this and there are places to draw
the line I mean Brian is right there are
these dram shop laws and Texas has its
own it says you have to be obvious
obviously intoxicated at the time of the
transaction so I think again Brian's
right you can have a defense that the
person wasn't obviously intoxicated but
I also think that some states take it
even further than that you don't even
have to be in a bar you can be at home
and serving alcohol and if someone goes
out and they injure or kill someone then
you can be held responsible for that but
Texas is not one of those States if
you're serving alcohol in Texas and
someone goes out and injures someone
else you're not going to be held
responsible for that but there are many
states that do hold these homeowners
responsible and it's really something
that they're doing to try to stop all of
these deaths that we're talking about on
the road when people get behind the
wheel and they've been drinking
hopefully it has the desired effect of
stopping this from happening and it's
kind of a wake-up call for people out
there Brian Terry thank you both so much
excellent work as always thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily we
will see you next time as we discuss
thanks I'll see you next time
[Music]